Welcome back.
Well we left off on
problem number 13.
But let me start it over just so
that we don't get confused
kind of doing the problem over
the course of two videos.
So number 13.
It starts off with
this pattern.
3, 5, minus 5.
And what it says in the problem
is that each even
number term is 2 more than
the previous term.
And then each odd number term
is negative 1 times the
previous term.
So we started with 3.
So let me say term-- let me
write it here, term-- term and
then value.
And then what we did.
Maybe we could call that
f of x or the function.
How did we go from one
value to the next?
So if we make a table,
term one is value 3.
And that's just the
starting one.
Term two is 5.
That's because we added
2, we added 2 to 3.
We could write 3 plus
2 is equal to 5.
Term three is minus 5.
And that's because minus 1 times
this 5-- let me draw
these arrows-- is equal
to minus 5.
And then we add again-- I'm
going to switch colors just to
keep it interesting.
So term four is going to be
minus 5 plus 2, which
equals minus 3.
Then term five is going to be
minus 3 times minus 1, which
equals 3 again.
Right?
And I think you see how we're
getting these patterns.
You just keep switching
between adding 2 and
multiplying by negative 1.
And then so term six is
going to be what?
It's going to be this
plus 2, which is 5.
I think you're seeing
the pattern again.
Let me do a bunch more and
I'll do it outside of the
scope of this chart.
The term seven is going
to be what?
It's going to be minus 1
times that, so minus 5.
And you see the pattern now.
Term eight is going
to be minus 3.
Term nine is going to be what?
Minus 3, minus 3.
So here we added 2 so we
multiply it by negative 1.
So it's going to be 3 again.
And you could just experiment
with yourself.
Once you understand how soon.
the sequence works, do a bunch
of terms until you
see a cycle.
And that's the key thing.
In any SAT problem, when
they ask you like what
is the 100th term?
It's going to have a cycle
because they don't expect you
to sit and write out 100
terms because you
would run out of time.
So if they ask you the 100th
term, the pattern probably
repeats every three or four or
five or, at most, six terms.
And then you can use that
to figure out what
the 100th term is.
So here we see that the pattern
repeats-- let's see,
3, 5, negative 5, negative 3.
3, 5, negative 5,
negative 3, 3.
So we see it repeats every
fourth term, right?
This is kind of one cycle, then
3, 5, negative 3, and
this is another cycle.
So it has this four pattern.
So can we come up with any term
that is a multiple of 4,
what is our value?
Well at 4 our value
is minus 3.
What's the next multiple of 4?
8.
At 8 our value's minus 3.
So in general-- and if we did
12 we'd also get minus 3.
If you don't believe me
you should try it out.
So at any multiple of 4, we
know our value is minus 3.
So what I do is, they want
to know the 55th term.
So what term is a multiple of
4 that's closest to 55?
Let's see, is 56 a
multiple of 4?
Yeah.
56-- that's 10.
14 times 4 is 56, right?
So the 56th term, we know the
56th term because 56 is a
multiple of 4, just like
4 and 8 and 12.
So the 56th term-- I have
trouble saying that.
Maybe I have a little lisp.
56th term is negative
3, right?
Because it's a multiple of 4.
If the 56th term is negative
3, what is the 55th term?
Well the term before the
negative 3 term is always the
negative 5 term, right?
Up here, negative 3?
It's always negative 5.
So the answer is negative
5 is the 55th term, and
that is choice A.
Very good.
All right, let's move on
to the next question.
I know that one's a little hard,
and those you always
just have to experiment a little
bit, try to see the
cycle, and then make sure you
have your terms right.
You know that you're starting
on the first term as opposed
to the 0 term.
And then figure out what the
easiest value is as close what
they're asking as possible and
then you can kind of move
backwards or forwards.
That's how I do it.
That's so you don't get too
confused with the shifts on
the terms.
All right, number 14.
In the xy plane, the equation
you of line l is-- let me
write that down-- number 14.
The equation of line l is
y is equal to 2x plus 5.
If the line m is the reflection
of l in the x-axis,
what is the equation
of line m?
So I'm going to draw a graph
for you, just so you
understand what I'm doing.
But on the real SAT you really
don't have to do this because
you wouldn't want to
run out of time.
Oh man, I'm going to run out
of time if I can't draw a
straight line.
I'm being a stickler for this.
Oh, I still couldn't do it.
I'll move forward.
So this line, so y
equals 2x plus 5.
So if you remember from our
slope and y-intercept modules,
the y-intercept's going
to be 5, right here.
And then the line's going
to have a slope of 2.
Right?
So the line's going to look
something like this.
That's line l.
This is line l.
And then we want to know, they
say line m is the reflection
of l in the x-axis.
So reflection would
kind of be the
x-axis-- this is the x-axis.
So it's like if we were looking
at this in a pool of
water, the reflection would be
like if you took this and
flipped it over the x-axis.
So the line m is going to look
something like this.
Line m is going to
look like this.
So a couple of things.
It's like the mirror image.
If we flipped it, it's like we
flipped it over the axis.
So if the y-intercept here is
5, the y-intercept here is
going to be minus 5.
Right?
Because we just flipped it.
And similarly, if every one
this moves up 2, right,
because that's at slope.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
2.
For every one we move here
to the right we're
going to go down 2.
So the slope is going to be
the negative of this or
negative 2.
So line m, so this is line m,
the equation of line m's going
to be y is equal to-- it's going
to have the negative
slope, right?
The same slope, but
it just moves in
the downward direction.
So it's going to be minus 2x.
And then its y-intercept is--
instead of plus 5 it's going
to be minus 5.
Minus 2x minus 5.
And that is choice A.
Looks like the next problem
involves a lot of drawing, and
I only have a minute and a
half left in this video.
So I will do the next problem
in the next video.
I will see